c'est un beau grèce il est trop beau il
est grand et également jamais bien non
franchement je suis contente
à moi aussi je suis très très content je
te plaît alors physiquement très grave
donc j'étais mis en bon bah j'ai fait
tous importants mais ça va t on tant de
baby foot jeux refus au taf futur est
quand même je suis très heureux de
recevoir gina et tomates en salade genii
thomas ça va très bien merci dany shihri
au pouvoir alors ce que vous pouvez vous
décaler un peu les chéris parce qu'on
voit pas de thomas n'est pas dans la
lumière
j'aimerais bien qu'on voit thomas merci
les chéris dont chennai thomas vous est
ce qui fait directement et dès le début
la quand on voit on voit que ça y est
c'est parti là assez direct on a parlé
pendant quelques mois ensemble ouais
franchement on attend des jeux ça ouais
c'est la vérité du coup bas bon il y
avait peut-être on était un mois j'étais
un peu un peu timide ouais mais ça va
après je me sens ça va tu t'es pas non
plus timides ou vraiment de raleigh
alors jean à toi tu as 22 ans
oui tu viens de mes yeux à côté de lyon
tu es vendeuse en parfumerie c'est ça
j'adore la parfumerie moi je m'en fous
départ mais j'adore je travaillais huit
ans chez sephora j'avais peur d'annoncer
quelque chose à thomas et c'est pas
n'importe quoi regarder comment je vais
faire part où je vais commencer
est-ce qu'il va accepter mon gros
mensonge comment ça va se passer quelle
va être sa réaction
c'est par un petit mensonge j'ai caché
vraiment enfants ou non bon maintenant
je vais être honnête avec toi j'espère
que tu vas pas m'en vouloir et j'espère
que je sais que tu vas tu vois pas mal
le prendre
ces machines
[Rires]
et alors on se demande 12 comment il a
réagi et bien regarder parce que moi
j'ai adoré le teasing d'ensisheim
franchement oui elle vient de lui
annoncer qu'elle a une fille comment
va-t-il réagir comment vous auriez réagi
ça va c'est pas non plus à leur petit
frère
j'ai un dinosaure à la maison mais ils
font tout pour nous mais j'ai regardé
mon fils mais mon fils était vénère
vas-y ils se prennent pour qui cette
fois c'est le pôle au samadhi promotion
très importante et c'est un point un peu
difficile pour moi de base commence à de
basses hadjar classique avec un homme en
cross corse est mort c'est pas que c'est
mort mais c'est pas un point
qui est favorable tu comprends c'est sûr
que l'on pourra pas peut-être faire ce
qu'on veut du coup tout le temps tu as
des impératifs
mais on prend maximum j'étais d'aller en
tout genre et trois jours trop shop
[Applaudissements]
hélas
comment est ce que la prod tu as dit je
suis sur moi thomas je dis la vérité
j'ai cerné un peu ton personnage moi je
suis sûr que ça ça ne dérangeait pas du
tout qu'elle est une fille m'a de base
on cherche pas ça déjà wallace dans la
vie après ça m'est tombé dessus mais ce
que la prod sadi est a prévenu avant de
ce qu'elle allait dire ou pas du tout
pas du tout pas du tout tu l'as tu l'as
pris quand elle va du canada dit non
mais c'est jeune hakim najib a déjà fan
et yann moreau gent féminine
et bah du coup je l'appris ans ou
directement jenna oui toi tête à tête en
bois c'est quand tu lui annoncer ça ou
pas où tu te disais ça va me regarder ça
m'a tout de suite c'est un mec non non
non je n'étais pas du tout angoissé de
façon je me suis dit c'est soit ils
acceptent tout ça elle accepte par en
fait comment je vais pas non plus me le
supplier ont tous quatre nomades dans
l'émission il a un truc qu'il fait
vraiment chier c'est la route
il a répété c'est vrai ça tombe pas
assez c'est sûr alors maintenant que
j'en ai tous les gêne à c'est compliqué
les deux photos c'est qu'on a c'est
qu'on fait on épand fuchs il aime trop
les mages m obama attend mais thomas tu
veux qu'on se parle tous les deux là
quand mes tomates en vrai et de bombes
atomiques cent grammes et jena lee sa
croyance et toi aussi tu es très beau
c'est ma came
voilà les barbus j'ai déjà fait mais
alors pourquoi tu ne renie pas c'est à
dire qu'elle s'est passé et eu la tête
était trop haute et pathé encore trop
volage ah non non je la kiffe gênant
c'est une personne vêtue l'acquittement
tu veux te gêne à d'autres modes dont ça
en fait jenna c'est quoi l'histoire dira
couteau sur lui sans réaliser ce que
c'est très simple bon il aime trop les
meufs
à chaque fois je trouve des messages de
maintenances août et les ravages pas
même la fin du xi
c'est pas des meufs c'est moi je sais
comme ça ça va j'essaie de un nom c'est
quoi ta trouver des messages de postes
sinon ouais moi si c'est des méchas de
boeuf comment ça va comment ça se fait
j'ai vu en extra la télé c'est un peu le
castaldi l'attrait d'expérience mais non
mais non mais sans il était octobre à
temps c'est peut-être des ex qui l'avait
oui et que maintenant c'est des coups
montés ce d'être après c'est possible je
ne sais pas mais en tout cas moi samassa
marquez qui cette fois ci mais je les
aime bien qu'est ce qui s'est passé
j'aimerais savoir ce qui s'est passé
donc vous étiez en sont donc après
l'émission qu'est-ce qui se passe donc
après l'émission ça se passe bien donc
on vous revoit quand on est ensemble la
commune et donc c'est ton mec donc c'est
mon mec c'est toi c'est à ce moment là
c'est ça
[Rires]
faire six ans tu auras tout le temps je
suis pas non plus goûté ces étapes donc
vous êtes ensemble ça alors et donc ça
dure quand même temps donc ça adjure bas
très longtemps au final quelques
semaines même pas quelques wild dizaine
de jours dizaine de jours et tous cas ce
que je vois le message mais comment ça
s'est passé sa main qui a vu le
téléphone tomates c'est tout simplement
une fille qui m'a contacté bain sur les
réseaux ouais et qui m'a envoyé un
message
oui voilà je suis jacobine de thomas jeu
je ne comprends pas j'aime vous voir
ensemble voilà donc dans un complot
c'est moi à ce moment thomas la
prochaine fois mais une fausse moustache
pourquoi et donc c'était vrai ch'ti soir
et ben oui à vérifier ben oui je lui en
ai parlé c'était c'est à dire c'était de
la jalousie
en fait ces jeux
[Musique]
alors qu'ils n'avaient plus rien son
rôle de haltes ont vu l onf et repartez
être sont dit tiens c'est maintenant
c'est le moment de revenir mais thomas
n'a pas l'air de se défendre je trouve
enfin ses six je me défends mais après
[Rires]
c'est vrai que j'aime état parce que je
la connais je vais faire je les connais
personnellement donc c'est vrai que
c'est pas des femmes comme ça n'a avancé
expliqué on a parlé ensemble il m'a dit
moi voilà c'est une fille que je voyais
ma chambre
après voilà alors investi à que ça non
mais non mais non mal passé de séducteur
oui marie thomas a passé de séducteur ah
bah oui voilà voilà alors thomas ça le
problème juste juste mon chien est ce
que tu as envie d'être avec jenna
sérieusement franchement jenna je vais
vraiment beaucoup aimé et après ça c'est
pas mal et ça se passe à deux tout ça
c'est pas moi qui vais casser
est ce que tu as envie tôt moi
personnellement oui après on a envie que
ce soit ta ta ta seule et unique meuf
série des blinis beaucoup que ça je vais
je connais non mais oui oui c'était pas
non quoi qu'il décide faut faire
attention il ya un petit ami
on a dit et redit vas-y joëlle mazart
assistons soutient hanni on n'a pas
nicolas pendant ces deux jours qu'on
aura d'or qui va revenir dès demain
nicolas pernikoff oui à mr afrique au
milieu oui mais deux minutes on n'essaie
pas son père lui voilà pour l'instant la
recherche par façon quoi qu'il arrive on
s'en occupe pas ce soit son ex elle
occupe très bien elle la dyle son
accident bien sûr je laisse pitié donc
là on parle d'amour donc thomas toi tu
es ce que tu as envie
est ce que toi dans ton for intérieur
est ce que tu as envie de faire une
histoire d'amour et de partir sur
l'autoroute de l'amour sans bhc 100 km
avec gêna faire 600 km pourquoi pas
c'est oui ou c'est non dit la vérité
pour moi personnellement ça me
dérangerait pas oui oui je suis derrière
[Applaudissements]
réponse à la fin tout ce qu'on appelle
des réponses à la fin non mais alors
donc thomas et tu sais pas trop et vous
êtes amoureux
voilà ce que tu amoureux c'est ça la
question non il ya une mauvaise saison
s'il vous plaît c'est bon là ici tu vas
faire ça moi je prends la parole on
s'aime beaucoup
après on peut pas tomber amoureux comme
ça d'accord ça s'appelle foudre il n'y a
pas eu de coup de foudre
il ya eu un petit coup de foudre mais
mamadou quand tu là quant à non mais
quand tu as budget n'a franchement si
c'est l'avion merci le move est très
sympathique
tu t'es pas dit ça y est c'est la salle
à femme de ma vie tu t'es dit non je
vais refaire 600 km j'ai pas besoin
n'habite pas très loin
abattement c'est un habitat de fenoyl
ouais d'accord a bien sûr non non mais
donc tu t es tu sens bon travail avec
loulou dans cette histoire il est là
pour déceler le vrai du faux
la vérité est ailleurs a exactement la
vérité est ailleurs
vous êtes vous avez déjà dormi ensemble
en dessous vous avez fait christie vista
toit de nanterre mauvais match vous avez
vous avez consommé nantes encore je sait
pas encore c'est pas ça veut pas
ça donnerait quoi alors qu'ils n'avaient
jamais couche en son nom c'est mignon
c'est bien la raison que vous connaissez
maintenant parce qu'on sait pas quand ça
a été tourné en fait on se connaît
depuis le mois de novembre minima depuis
février en septembre
au bout de sa vie la preuve la sincérité
du vote chaînage et là je vous dis je un
coup de coeur djenad eu un coup de coeur
et thomas aussi je rêve je l'adorais wu
lyf thomas voilà il rit un sourire je
kiffe cia il a quelque chose il me jean
veil
les deux cas ils partent pour l'éternité
on va demander justice on a dit aux
responsables de l'amour qui si gilbert
dlc c'est dix huit ans d'échec c'est
plus de 1500 vont pas sous pression
pesci rios mais tu viens vous êtes fait
pour être ensemble mais je pense qu'à
une timidité
jenna vous voulez vraiment récupérer est
ce que vous vous êtes amoureuse n'en
attendaient que oui non mais on n'a pas
demandé de poser des questions a demandé
de faire un bilan
oui alors il ya 15 ans et chaud il ya
quelque chose qui entravent l'amour ha
soit quelqu'un quelque part un passé
mais je pense qu'il faut surmonter ça et
vous avez un avenir à construire
envoyez-moi la fonction fond c'est vous
vous aimez je le vois dans vos yeux
alors c'est à dire la vérité oui je peux
dire ce que ce sens bien je suis tout le
contraire de gilbert non je vous le dis
je crois que gilbert décès encore fausse
route une fois de plus sans rigoler la
ruche pour vous dire c'est un trio fut
que ça veut dire que c'est pas possible
d'être au toit côté de la plaque je suis
pas sûr à côté de la plaque
guillot comment vous sortez scoop je
pense que c'est mort les faux espoirs
ben barka bâ est ce que vous vous rendez
compte t il sur le plateau nommé oui
d'accord mais qu'on pige au mac
elle a raison en tout cas s'il n'est pas
sérieux et qu'ils ne l'aiment pas la
raison de le faire avant de moi c'est
beau cette gêne à je voulais c'est le
temps de la pub puis pour réfléchir
répondent aux quais et vous allez venir
dans un instant tous les deux si vous
souhaitez partir seul ou séparément non
ensemble ou séparément est lui aussi
d'accord où vous me direz ça dans un
instant bien saison top
thomas et jen a alors eu je vais on va
voir d'autres extraits d'émissions et
après je vous demanderais ce qui va en
advenir de vous de vous deux vous n'avez
qu'un grand v un virage elle y avait un
autre couple qui a beaucoup fait parler
ils ont pu découvrir les téléspectateurs
sofia et maeva aulas parle sur les
réseaux sociaux depuis trois mois sauf
que maeva vu le nombre d'allusions
qu'elle a fait pendant leur rencontre en
sang qu'elle n'est pas venue des ballons
merci quand donc sa crise ouverte mais
aussi sacré sourire g-shock allemand ah
ouais je suis jamais déshabille toi
la desert victoire si je suis faudra que
ce soit en formant un bon bah oui
[Musique]
d'autres dons à d'autres comme en un an
je peins jusqu'ici pour dormir
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je t'attends dit
c'est rapide je vous assure c'est très
bien mais c'est vrai qu on s'est dit là
franchement à la bien pour faire un
mille bornes
oui moi je suis déçu parce que je trouve
que tous les couples sont extrêmement
sincère à la pour la première fois j'ai
trouvé ça un peu fait que j'avais
l'impression qu'elle en faisait trop
pour les caméras alors regardez ça se
passe pas hyper bien en fait dans la
chambre après ouais regarder que c'était
si je croyais pas tu vois pas ce que
vous correspondra pas besoin tous
attendent ce soir je serai pas là bon ok
[Musique]
si je te kiffe vraiment je ferai pas
pourquoi
c'est du coup sauf et un parc de jeu
race est associé à une condition que
dans son cas répartis dans l'ensemble
bien s'asseoir et discuter
vivement cette nuit pour que je puisse
qu'il prouve et qui je suis vraiment ça
sera pas ma première nuit d'amour avec
sofia mais ça sera déjà ma première nuit
avec elle et ça c'est déjà une grande
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
émission c'est l'antichambre des
émissions de téléréalité on voit ici
pour se montrer et je vous parie tout ce
que vous voulez quand même pas du doigt
je suis pas moi c'est assez routinier
tout ce que vous voulez que je vous
allez retrouver cette jeune femme dans
une autre émission de télé réalité
les bulles fake à des kilomètres elle
n'est pas sincère pour moi absolument
pas hélas les voix vous n'allez pas
l'amour non elle a raison sur la radio
de l'amour et il était resté l'amour tu
seras content qu'elle part en contre
avec cela ce dernier il était l'aîné
mediapart est un chien ne tue pas du
tout d'accord c'est pas parce que les
démarches sont pas les mêmes que c'est
non sincère tiffany là vous vous trompez
totalement elles ont une différence
d'âge n'était pas venu pour la même
chose mais franchement ils auraient pu
ses mélodies parce que je suis ton ami
oui tu aimes plus l'amour gils topless
et pas et l'émission de saxe est une
émission d'amour quand même donc quand
tu dis elles sont pas venus pour la même
chose moi je suis pas daccord
normalement elles viennent toutes les
deux pour l'amour donc quand on voit une
qui vient pour le sexe est une qui vient
pour l'amour et ben moi celle qui vient
pour l'amour et ben je suis contente
pour elle qu'elle ait vu le vis de
l'autre personne et qu'elle ne se soit
pas fait avoir
parce qu'elle est tellement magnifique
scène enfin ce qu'elle aurait pu se
laisser les sabres c'est bien mais elle
est là elle a eu peur en plus à l'aise
il faut que je résiste cogérer this way
elle a résisté
il a eu raison moi j'ai bien aimé j'ai
bien aimé les deux alors il ya eu un
troisième couple aussi le dernier le
sexe est pas à une pépite c'est jean
marc et olga ça fait une semaine qui se
parlaient sur les réseaux sociaux
j'avais déjà très envie de se rencontrer
problème olga lui ont envoyé juste une
photo où on la voyait qu'à moitié
voilà est en fait et quand il a vu il
n'était pas comme un arrêté de galeries
c'est vrai qu'on a jamais parlé
d où donc j'ai vu que la petite vignette
en fait qu'il définissait cents de
profits sur la vignette et jolie la plus
dès le premier regard ça c'est sûr j'ai
trouvé qu'elle avait un joli visage la
d2 jo lisieux à la bnr mignonne
physiquement j'ai craqué ça va ça va
je suis un peu surpris par rapport à ce
que j'avais vu sur la photo sur le
coucher je la reconnais pas complètement
donc c'est vrai que je suis déçu a
envoyé la voiture vous dire la vérité je
t'ai je vous jure que c'est vrai je vous
parle ni sérieuse armes
je trouve pas qu'il n'est non pas du
tout si j'ai la même personne nicolas
l'écho massoma voilà c'est oui moi je
suis d'accord cette dame déjà 2 1 elle
est très jolie a les traits de deux
caisses qui croient que jean-marc la 54
ans il croit qu elle avoir une jeune
femme de 25 ans qui à l'arrivée ils
nourrissent toutes pimpantes comme ça
pour lui mais il rêve et elle est très
belle et je vois pas où est le problème
je suis passé mais physiquement on dit
juste que les photos non jacques cady
enfin mais ne correspond pas celle que
l'on croit lui banon mais sans être
sexiste et sans émettre de jugement
c'est vrai qu'elle est très jolie mais à
quel moment quand vous mettez une photo
comme ça vous pensez qu'on va rien dire
quand on l'a vu en vrai c'est pas la
même personne que j'aimais pas de
jugement mais s'il ya une personne
serait pas plus bas la mort non mais
j'ai pas là qu'elle avait dévoilés en
personne il faut quand même se méfier
des filtres franchement voilà vous
devriez ans m
à la question la question maintenant les
savoirs parce que vous êtes là
j'aimerais savoir
on a une relation virtuelle pendant
plusieurs semaines de monsieur lui mais
c'était juste une semaine
qu'est ce qui fait qu'on accepte alors
qu'on est dans un cocon de la virtualité
on va aller dans le réel qu'est ce qui
fait qu on va accepter ce genre de
programme vous avez compris la question
d'accepter d'aller à la télévision
devant des caméras alors que la lumière
était quand même très intimidant pour
dire que peut-être potentiellement vous
allez vous aimez moi tout simplement
j'ai tout simplement j'ai accepté parce
que
bah c'était sympa c'est un autre à dire
c'est un peu comme on gère une exception
un peu baba comme les autres de se
rencontrer pour la première fois et ça
et on voit la vraie la situation génère
ce que vous avez envie de faire de la
télé bah pourquoi pas ah voilà ce que
mais pourquoi tu pars plein de gens on
se dit ils font cette émission aussi
peut-être pour être repéré pour pouvoir
faire après non non non droit du cm1 pas
forcément avancer son propre et de la
télé je cherchais vraiment l'amour vous
aviez eu vraiment un coup de coeur bio
bas j'ai eu un coup de coeur pour thomas
oui par textos quand j'ai quand j'ai
appris à le connaître quand on se
parlait tout ça oui bin on en mairie le
sial barre symboli leucan bar tu veux
quoi votre canne bar on voit mon caleçon
oui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
thomas et jenna donc une thomas est ce
que toi tu veux repartir avec jenna ou
séparément quoi ça non plus ce gars
l'enjeu le feu il est timide en fait al
etienne jaime reina
oui c'est aussi un contrôle d'histoire
oui oui elle est pourquoi on va on va
essayer quand tu as envie de lui
redonner sa chance
ouais mais est-ce que tintin tu
amoureuse de lui non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je m'en bats les coutures giscard
repartir avec jenna jambes en partance
et coupez pas d'être ensemble
elle essayait de faire une histoire on
va le faire
est-ce que tu as mon road et jenna non
j'ai pas mort de jenna d'accord on sait
j'ai du mal à tomber amoureux d'un bon
air et novartis cette histoire allez on
arrête tous dit la vérité n'a pas du
tout été avec thomas bah moi là
maintenant l'heure d'aujourd'hui non en
fait
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
non non et toi thomas non voulait être
copains en fait on s'entend super bien
voilà il est dommage qu'on se parle plus
du tout quoi donc vous préférez garder
une relation d'amitié
henson frais jonway tuto paintball les
deux thomas je te sens pas comme un ouf
ses friends own fan zones d'accord très
c'est bon c'est sa faune zone reste avec
nous quand même ravi puisque jour
poserai la question du salaire